journalists in fear the end of press
freedom that's the question we want to
address today on quadriga hello and
welcome World Press Freedom Day is just
around the corner would you dear
audience risk your lives to tell the
truth journalists and bloggers around
the world are doing it on a daily basis
they are information hunters but they
themselves are often the hunted in war
zones in authoritarian societies
increasingly even in democracies whether
Mexico or China Turkey or Poland
pressure is rising on those who report
the facts mistrust censorship and
persecution rather than freedom and
respect an alarming downward spiral and
that's what we want to talk about today
with three guests who have been directly
affected by declining Press Freedom Mira
Jamal is a freelance journalist from
Pakistan she had to leave the country
because her life was endangered due to
her work she believes that journalism
without press freedom becomes a work of
fiction and loses contact with reality
on the ground
Mona Kareem belongs to a Bedouin family
from Kuwait they are stateless like many
Bedouins they fell through the cracks
when Kuwait became independent in 1961
as a blogger she says journalism under
authoritarianism becomes the best tool
of resistance and it's a pleasure to
welcome Andrea Skloot he's a German
American journalist and berlin-based
correspondent for The Economist
he says a French philosopher once said
every country gets the government it
deserves
today we know every country also gets
the press it deserves freedom of the
press is today the first signal of
freedom generally so let me start out
with you miss Jamal and asked you to
tell us just a bit about your personal
story you found yourself unable to work
in your own country in Pakistan how and
why the situation in Pakistan is quite
different to what we see here the social
pressure the religious pressure their
political pressure see as journalists if
you look at things with different
perspective than
the mass perspective then you find
yourself in danger anyhow so as a woman
I was in danger as a person without
beliefs I was in danger and as a
journalist if I try to bring those
things into limelight that whatever was
going wrong I was in danger as I
understand that you had been doing some
reporting on women on children's
situation
even on prostitutes none of that is
directly what you got you into trouble
what got you into trouble was writing
about a cram school what happened then
no actually I was getting emails and
hate mails as you called it right now on
my women rights issue articles as well
but Koran hula it was like hitting the
head on the nail the nail on the head
the thing was that it is such a
sensitive topic for most of the
Pakistanis that you you can't question
religion and if they are sending their
children to a Quran Shuler or a Koran
school then they have the right to do so
and you can't question the method that
they used to teach there whether it's
using the stick or hitting them abusing
them in any way they just accept it
that's how it is and I wrote I try to
write about it and got myself into
trouble exactly what kind of trouble
briefly what happened to you then
threats
I was encountered by people with knives
want who threatened me personally they I
was getting phone calls emails
everything that if I don't quit I'd get
myself into trouble Mona Kareem a [ __ ]
then on your story as well what were you
reporting on in Kuwait what kind of
experiences did you have I was working
in a newspaper and really my work in the
newspaper wasn't that controversial four
four four authorities because already
media is is very well controlled you
know so when not only by the state court
or even the owners of the media you know
do not want to pass any criticism but in
in my blogging you know especially after
Twitter and Facebook and the Arab Spring
all that context but so much visibility
you know to whatever criticism you bring
so when that happened today
eleven I was using my blog and Twitter
to report on protests by the stateless
community that I belong to that upset
authorities they don't want these news
to come out you know they don't want you
know the news on arrest for example to
come out so um the reaction was you know
some harassment and and and hate mail I
was not arrested but I certainly was
questioned you know for speaking up and
the harassment was coming from whom from
official government sources yes mostly
mostly from officials of course they
don't do it in in a diet and documented
way you know because that might trouble
them somehow but as you mentioned you
know interrogations questions phone
calls you know threats and on the other
side of course you get all these
anonymous people on the internet sending
you messages and to scare you off and
you never know even if these people who
are sent by the government or
voluntarily doing it you mentioned that
you came from a group of people who were
considered stateless meaning you had no
citizenship you had no passport how did
you get yourself out of the country you
now live in New York yes
so my community to say it briefly you
know don't have any sort of
documentation going all the way to a
birth certificate or a marriage
certificate access to education and
health all of that so but some of us
would rarely get you know a childhood
document that can be used one time and
to leave the country and that's what
happened in my case especially that I
was a journalist so after you leave you
never allowed back you know it was a way
to let's say in direct exile and you
know they wait for you to leave and
never allow you again perhaps it's worth
noting for our audience our two guests
were comparing their situations
beforehand neither of them can go back
to their home countries both of them
have refugee travel documents rather
than passports so to speak
andreas Clute you talked about the fact
that a country's press is essentially
also a signal of how much freedom if it
allows would you say as are we
Porter for the economist you come from
countries you're both German and
American in which press freedom is
intact I certainly feel lucky as I think
you do as well have to listen to these
two stories that you're right I'm German
I'm American my employer is British I
have three countries three Western
countries that value freedom of the
press in different ways in suddenly
different ways but they value them and
I've never felt any pressure overtly
there although I've had recently my
first Twitter if I may say so so
shitstorm that's no a town now I had a
bit of that a phenomenon and I think
that's an interesting one to get into I
once covered from Hong Kong Mainland
China for the Economist we used to I've
never felt a major threat but it was an
open secret that we were assigned
translators and drivers and whenever we
went into the mainland they followed us
around our phones were tapped we knew
that it was almost a subject to to amuse
ourselves about so I've been privileged
I feel especially compared to these two
you also mentioned something else which
i think is quite relevant briefly
touched on by ms karim as well namely
self-censorship when you were based in
hong kong can you just say a word about
that we can get into it and more but
it's important to keep in mind that of
course government censorship authority
and regimes is the traditional threat
that we're all looking out for but there
are other forms and one is
self-censorship it was just an example
from when I was on Hong Kong at the time
the the big discussion the controversy
there was not over whether the Hong Kong
government was part of China but a one
country two systems' the Hong Kong
government was not trying to censor any
press but some of the press organs were
owned by tycoons so-called who wanted to
ingratiate themselves with Beijing and
maybe you can have private sector
self-censorship it's been an issue in
Britain with the Murdoch press etc there
are these other elements censorship and
threats to press freedom can sometimes
come from sources other than the
government let's take a closer look at
exactly that aspect namely the different
forms that repression can take and I'd
like to just take a look at the world
press freedom map that we have we have
World Press Freedom Day around the
corner and reporters without borders
puts out a map where we can see the
degree to which press freedoms are under
threat and essentially what we see there
more countries where press freedom is
under threat than where press freedom is
open so many many places in the world
press freedom is on retreat Reporters
Without Borders says Europe has the
freest media we see it here in the map
Africa interestingly enough coming in in
second place surpassing the Americas for
the first time Eastern Europe Central
Asia North America Middle East they all
find themselves toward the bottom of the
ratings so I'd like to stay for a while
in the Middle East and Islamic world and
look at some of the forms that
suppression can take there and let me
ask you miss Jamal you talked about
feeling threatened as I understand it a
lot of these threats came from
individuals but would you say in the end
that the government was letting that
happen also as a way to suppress you the
biggest threat of being in Pakistan is
that I was an atheist and you can't say
that if I say that in public I'll be
murdered
there are lots of incidents of Christian
being hacked to death and burn to death
and there are the violence in the
society is growing so much that it's out
of control and the state the Islamic law
that we have all shelters that so it's
not like you know if someone kills a
person who has converted out of Islam
they they are justified to do that
because the state a punishment for that
is also there so the rise of
sectarianism feeding the kind of results
that we saw there on the map when we
look at the Middle East or North Africa
would you agree miss curry yes certainly
I think also authoritarian regimes say
in the Gulf for example have used the
sectarian card as a way you know to
refer the first cue it's activists and
join the list you know as you said you
eat that one way to persecute them is to
allow
people to troll them and to threaten
them and you know have no accountability
to safeguard these voices you know so
it's not only one method of suppression
by jailing them and interrogating them
but even allowing others to do it and
there are governments such as the
Bahraini government that hired you know
PR companies based went in Europe and
the u.s. to specifically do that twelve
people and you know defamed them and and
and deprive them of their legitimacy and
when talking can I just ask was religion
an issue in your case now the religion
wasn't an issue in my case I'm most of
my work has been about the stateless but
also immigrants in the Gulf and what
kind of legal obstacles are you know
they face and persecution ot but
essentially you were the voice of a
minority at any rate an ethnic minority
and rescued are we seeing the rise not
only in these regions of the world North
Africa and Middle East but even here in
Eastern Europe of something you might
call majoritarianism the idea that it's
only the majority's voice that can and
should be heard I'm not sure we're that
we're seeing the rise of it but I am
sure that that's always been one of the
classic threats to freedom in fact James
Madison one of the founding fathers of
America made that he coined that word
majoritarianism and he was thinking back
to ancient Athens which was a pure
democracy when he was writing to the
Americans at the time we were trying to
figure out how to to create a Free
Republic it'd be careful if we just it
doesn't just mean democracy all the time
we've oh Thanh everything then we get
what's happening in some of these places
that you mentioned then the majority
will oppress the minority to a large
extent freedom is actually the right the
protection of minorities against
majorities it's a mixture that's why
they created the Republic and I think
that as an eternal dance between
majoritarianism where the minority live
in fear and that's not freedom and in a
sort of more balanced regime between
democracy with checks and balances and a
separate judiciary and a separate Free
Press so that everyone one can be free
including free from each
and from majorities would you subscribe
to that same view miss Jamal and if so
how can someone in Pakistan who wants to
bring a minority perspective into the
open how can they do it
recently it's going to be made
impossible because they're trying to
pass a cybercrime bill in Pakistan which
has been approved by the lower house of
the Parliament and do that law ensures
that anyone who speaks anything against
the government the army religion or
political personality is they'll be
imprisoned or fined up to ten million
rupees so it's like you you just put a
tape on their mouth and do you expect
them to do journalism or to speak about
it and it's not gonna happen because
they they have hired a team of IT
experts and they are going to control
everything that goes online on air on
any line on telephone and everything
interesting that they use cyber methods
to do it clearly they see the Internet
as a major threat you said in your
opening statement miss Kareem blogging
is the best way to resist
authoritarianism or majoritarianism why
is that well I think you know since say
the Iraq war when that was the context
when when blogging came to the picture
and was really powerful in the state for
many years now blogging is replaced by
say Twitter you know in social media and
I think now people are leaving social
media into channels that are more
private where you can be less visible
less you know vulnerable to persecution
so yes I think blogging is a great
alternative to classical media however
it's also being threatened against oh
good enough that people are creative in
trying to resist this oppression let's
take a closer look
some young bloggers in Tunisia have
become the or became the face of their
country's resistance
she gave young Tunisians a face and a
voice during the heady days of the Arabs
Leyna then many blogged about the
revolution going on in her country and
the world read along the government
tried to censor her entries but the
young activists refused to give in to
intimidation in 2011 DW honored her at
the best of blog Awards for her entry a
tunisian girl the north african country
has become a glimmer of hope for
democracy in the arabic-speaking world
our bloggers the new front line in the
fight for democracy and freedom of the
press Andres would you say bloggers do
have more freedom more impact than
traditional journalists no certainly not
that but that there's more but what what
blogging and now micro blogging like
Twitter tweeting and so forth has done
is a certain kind of revolution that
I've compared to Gutenberg's printing
press revolution in the 15th century
which launched the Reformation the
Renaissance the modern era this blogging
and these micro tools in effect give
each of us a printing press and there's
a multitude of voices that used to be
inaudible that are now audible that's
what I meant when I said that every
country every society now gets the press
it deserves we're all part of this
conversation if we blog banal things
hateful things we deserve the press we
get there that is the climate the
atmosphere we create if we if we try to
inform ourselves try to think try to
analyze then that's the kind of press we
get so in a very direct way it's it's
included more it's broadened audiences
made them part of the conversation
generally this is a good thing to what
degree does that broadening the
multiplier effect the visibility to what
degree does that serve to protect a
journalist we saw in the report that
this young blogger had been given
airtime by DW and in that way made more
visible but I know that you had won an
award from the US State Department you
were visible you had been recognized and
yet in the end it didn't help what
didn't help was me coming here and being
away from the situation that I was in
kind of the audience or the readers I
should say
here are not interested in the problems
of the people in Pakistan a layman's
problem
a woman who struggles every day to get
out of her house and to educate her
children how the poverty affects people
how the rate of education is so low in
our country so these things I feel that
they don't get much more exposure as
they need to and these were the subjects
that I was offering and this it seems
there's no market for it so you have
less material to work with now that you
are in exile essentially but coming back
to the fact that you had received public
official recognition from the US State
Department while you were still in
Pakistan and yet it didn't protect you
the problem is that I can't try it in
Pakistan anymore because once you apply
for an asylum it has a kind of a state
effect and the newspaper and the media
houses back there they are afraid to
print my walk because that might get
them into trouble and this is kind of a
mentality that goes by and so here I
need either I should find my niche here
or just forget about it I know mr. MA
has said she actually regrets the fact
that she can't go back in some ways
regrets the fact that she is now based
here would you say the same about being
based in New York can you do the work
you want to do or has you how do you
also feel cut off from your material
yeah I think I do feel cut off and I I
had to decide at some point that you
know this is this is the context now of
someone else you know and it's their
struggle and my like the possible thing
for me is to think that you know I have
some privilege and I can be a backup for
them you know so there is always like as
I as I mentioned when arrests happened
people from inside might be watching out
from mentioning these details but I can
do that you know I can't talk about the
case of friends being tortured in prison
you know so whenever I can you know I
fill in but certainly it becomes now the
work of someone else to pick up and keep
on with it
you are both living
in the West now I'd like to take a brief
look at the situation of the west of the
press in the West because here too it is
under attack from populist politicians
for example who often accused the press
of lying in 2015 German prosecutors
brought charges against Marcos Bekaa da
for betraying state secrets the
journalist had published leaked internal
papers from the country's Secret Service
the charges were eventually dropped but
journalists now feared they could be put
under surveillance many members of the
right-wing pegida movement viewed
journalists as little more than liars
and purveyors of propaganda at
demonstrations reporters have been
repeatedly insulted and even physically
attacked
and plurality in the press is also under
threat as economic pressure rises more
and more media outlets are now gathered
in fewer and fewer hands at the same
time newsrooms are being streamlined and
downsized is freedom of the press in
Germany in danger and risk loot what do
you think how would you answer that
question you said yourself freedom of
the press is the first sign of freedom
generally we have seen attacks on
journalists here at the rallies of
pegida that was just shown there in the
report we also have just seen the
Chancellor saying an investigation can
go ahead against a comedian whom the
president of Turkey accuses of insulting
him is that press freedom first of all
there's absolutely no threat to press
freedom in Germany yeah this is now
we've now gone from a shifted it made a
quantum leap to another it's a matter of
proportion this is part of the eternal
debate over whether the press is doing
its job well whether it has the trust of
the population but there's no actual
this is self-correcting now what what
you see though is interesting in fact in
Germany I as an outsider as working for
a British magazine coming here from
America do feel that the press corps and
for instance the politicians are in a
strangely much more cozy relationship
with each other than in America which is
much where it is much more adversarial
and where people like it that way
especially after some scandals that
happened in the run-up to the for the
second Gulf War in the press ok that has
not happened in Germany and I think some
in some of these conspiracy theories
that you see no Buy in groups like
pegida the alternative for Germany they
they are similar to conspiracy theories
we've had for many years in America for
instance in the demographic that was the
Tea Party and so forth and essentially
it falls down to that the mainstream
media or what they call the lamestream
media is politically correct and self
sensors in some way it is actually true
there are studies that in Germany for
instance the the a journalist are they
over represent certain central
the Green Party certain opinions and
underrepresented us they're not a mirror
of the society and I think there is a
certain group think okay that is again
this is self-correcting that that in in
the press landscape others will come
forward and fill the gaps that's already
happening that's the market at work
however I do think at the moment that
there is a genuine case to be made
that's not the one they're making it
pegida
but I could make a genuine case that
German journalism is to club' to cozy to
koi and doesn't always serve the
population well which of course is what
happened in the US and you run-up to the
Iraq war where the Washington Post
simply bought the whole government line
I'd like to hear from both of you you
are now based in Germany managed Amal
Amano Kareem is now based in the US
what's your sense of the situation of
the press in those countries just
absolutely rosy or are there areas where
you would say it's questionable for you
as compared to from where we come it's
totally rosy I think they are the risk
that we had back there are quite
different from the risk that journalists
have here so it's led to they have here
briefly in case if there if there's like
being attacked by the mob like in pagada
rally but in Pakistan it's the
government it's the military
intelligence it the other agencies that
can just report you missing after
certain days you'll be gone no trace the
screen well I I think when it comes to
US media it's it's very much polarizing
and I don't think there is anything
special about mainstream media in the US
but of course I'll tentatively there are
people trying to be creative with
whatever they offer for me as a refugee
there you know I think media is not
helping me you know correct the
discourse or even you know bring anyone
into the conversation
and with the rise of what we can say the
right thing you know it's it's becoming
even more personal so yeah
a journalist does not get written
personally but is there is there a
context for that anyways thank you very
much to all of you for being with us
here today and thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in see you soon